joyeuse Saint-Valentin
[Applaudissements]
alors figurez-vous que pour l'occasion
j'ai des petits cadeaux à vous offrir
alors bien sûr vous qui êtes devant
votre poste de télévision je ne peux pas
mais sachez que c'est un peu à vous
aussi que je les
gentil et j'en profite pour vous
déclarer ma flamme Babette en ce jour de
Saint-Valentin avec le chalumeau
qu'utilisera à notre chef pour préparer
ce lendemain de méchoui
[Rires]
aujourd'hui pour la Saint-Valentin votre
centre Depil tech vous offre moins 30%
sur l'épilation du maillot parce qu'on
est d'accord qu'une Saint-Valentin avec
le persil qui dépasse du cabas c'est
cracra
Sandrine esthéticienne à Fourtou nous
dit j'aimerais avoir une pincée pour
toutes les collègues aujourd'hui on va
enquiller 150 épilation dans la journée
on pensait être esthéticienne en fait on
est jardinière municipales avec tous ces
poils je vais pouvoir rembourrer des
coussins quel métier oui d'accord
Sandrine mais peut-être que grâce à vos
épilations parfaites il y aura beaucoup
d'amour ce soir et donc dans 9 mois il y
aura un baby-boom donc plus d'enfants
donc plus de travailleurs donc une
économie florissante et donc à chaque
fois que vous épiler un maillot vous
payez une retraite les nerfs dans
l'hémicycle il aura suffi d'un mois un
peu familier emprunté pour qu'il parte
dans un fou rire mais alors un fou rire
ah ils se sont bidonnés tu vois les
baleines voilà la même chose
il a rien à fout il a rien à faire dans
le dans le pfff
vous jouez avec toi à la maison quelle
est cette partie du corps partie du
corps en argot
Didier baloche vous avez dit les
paloches vous avez dit baloches Didier
ma sur le buzzer question de sur le
buzzer
on a retrouvé Tom
[Applaudissements]
mains sur le désor et en 14 février
évidemment le président du groupe
horizon à l'Assemblée avait très hâte de
célébrer la Saint Valentin ça ne passe
pas par beaucoup de solutions vous avez
la solution qu'il y a visé à baiser
baisser les cotisations
le soleil ne va pas être que dans les
cœurs il va être partout sur la carte et
puis que les météos enfin les
températures vont être un tout petit peu
coquines pas ce matin mais cet
après-midi parce qu'elles vont donner
envie de se des vêtir
cette image a été énormément vue
à gauche
non
non non
parce que c'est
la permissivité
de droite parce que la Saint-Valentin il
y a le côté tradition de fête de l'amour
et les traditions ben valeurs de droite
vous êtes dans la provocation et vous
c'est votre droit je ne critique pas
même
si je sors dans la rue complètement à
poil avec des plumes dans le plus rien
ne justifie qu'on vient de me toucher en
fait bah moi ça me choque autant les
deux voilà
j'ai le droit de le dire
un mot
politique ça je vois pas quelle partie
c'est non
des électeurs en couple
des acteurs de Marine Le Pen en couple
faites la Saint-Valentin et ils ne sont
que 30% chez les électeurs de gauche et
d'extrême gauche d'accord
monsieur des légumes madame guetter
bonjour si je demande un mot pour
décrire Clémentine Autain
réponse très classe de l'ancien
chauffeur de Jean-Luc Mélenchon pourquoi
parler de transformer moi je suis
maintenant que vous étiez trans j'ai cru
que vous étiez juste une femme donc je
suis désolé je suis peut-être
[Rires]
débilement vous êtes magnifique madame
j'ai cru juste voilà vous étiez une
femme ont touché la poitrine bon ce
n'est pas bien je ne cautionne pas
évidemment mais arrêtez de mettre de la
transphobie là où il y en a pas
je vous aime
[Applaudissements]
je n'en connais pas facile
je n'ai pas de fragile
je discute avec Sébastien parce que je
suis pas complètement blonde en vrai
c'est quoi cette réponse blonde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'en tape dans la vie
repères aux gens contre un poteau de ce
que tu fais toi tu fais tu veux qu'on se
tape ou quoi là je vais péter ta race
samedi soir le vrai gagnant des brides
c'était l'alcool et la plus belle sortie
de route c'est celle-là ça n'a rien fait
d'accord ça vous va ici est-ce que vous
avez quelque chose à dire
je suis la Liberté guidant le peuple
merci au revoir au revoir merci et si
c'est par là la première à droite pas à
gauche enfin vous vous trouverez
Sébastien Chenu qui était très pressé de
rentrer chez lui son débit en fin de
séance la trahi c'est sans trucage
prochaine séance demain 15h question
gouvernement suit du projet loi de
financement
2023 bonne nuit à demain allez
excusez-moi il est au perchoir où il
dirige un manège de fête foraine